[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
hello Alexander I'm the executive
director at the long now foundation
Stewart unfortunately can't be here
tonight he's accepting an award in
Chicago
but I'm glad that all of you are in
light of the opening games tonight of
the Olympics clearly some of you made it
out instead of watching the smog in
China I'd also just like to thank those
of you who did come to the mechanic role
actually can I see hands how many people
came Oh quite a few awesome so we had
over a thousand people we had no idea
how many people would come and it was
great to see over a thousand people come
and check out the all the amazingness
that is in San Francisco's Fisherman's
Wharf that nobody ever gets to see
except for the tourists of course
tonight Peter Schwartz will be doing the
Q&A after the talk and I just wanted to
give a little bit of the back story it's
actually nice that Stewart isn't doing
this because Stewart's actually a bit of
the fairy godmother of the of this story
which is he he read our blog review by
Rick Clow of this book who the the book
was sent to him by Daniel Suarez his
wife and total cold-called used the
thing that says that everybody says it
doesn't work and he actually read it
which nobody ever does and then he
reviewed it and he gave it a really
great review and Stewart saw it and then
bought the book and put it on his shelf
and it was and there it's at for many
months and finally he pulled it off his
shelf when he was looking for a new
novel and he read it and he was amazed
the book was really pushing new ground
it was doing it in a new way
not with necessarily new technology but
by combining new technology in a totally
fresh and interesting way and in some
cases a pretty scary way since that time
he also introduced Daniel to Peter
Schwartz who connected connected him to
Walter Parks of DreamWorks and so
there's now a DreamWorks movie deal on
it's on its way anyway and to book deal
with Dutton publishers so the
books that we have are the remaindered
copies from the original purchase we
have they're all signed out there but
they're the last ones of this
self-published edition so if you don't
get these you're not going to be able to
get the new edition until January 9th
they'll be available here and in our
store afterwards and soon until until
we're out you'll be able to get them so
Daniel tonight is going to be talking
about the kind of themes that he worked
on in this book he's not gonna be
necessarily talking about the book
itself but like Neuromancer and Snow
Crash this this type of book when you
read it you realize you're reading
something new and important and you will
be riveted and he puts together the
technology in a way that that I think is
very important for our civilization in a
way that Vernor Vinge II is now working
on as well and here to talk about that
tonight is Daniel Suarez Thank You
Alexander good evening everybody now
some of you might be wondering what
qualifies a novelist to speak on the
topic of bought mediated reality so I'd
like to address that first off who the
hell is Daniel Suarez well I'm a
software guy the last 17 years I've been
designing and developing database
management systems for large companies
now I've been doing this in many
industries defense finance logistics
entertainment and for the last seven
years with my own company now over the
course of my career I've noticed
society's collective pursuit of hyper
efficiency this has been a great concern
of mine because it's been a pursuit of
efficiency at the expense of almost
everything else now efficiency manifests
itself in several ways
first of all centralization that's
companies merging becoming ever larger
achieving economies of scale and fewer
people making decisions that affect
larger numbers of people and that
baguettes a monoculture that's vast
uniform networks not just digital but
agricultural industrial financial media
and part of this is also an elimination
of redundancy that is trimming fat now
in nature there's a use for fat it's to
deal with disruptions big business tries
to minimize the amount of fat and part
of it also is a drive for ubiquitous
connectivity that is unifying all of
these vast networks to achieve
centralized data management and analysis
there's all of these things in the
pursuit of efficiency that make it
possible to achieve widespread
automation and by that I mean software
automation or BOTS and that's what I'm
here to talk about tonight because bots
are increasingly what we rely on to make
decisions for us as a matter of fact
we're increasingly taking our
instructions directly from BOTS
sometimes just on faith takes a while I
think this is in the Olympic Village I'm
not sure now my book demon for those of
you who aren't familiar with the
scenario of that book this story is one
of a game designer or designs an array
of bots that scan the internet for the
appearance of his obituary and when it
appears on his death these bots launch
into action and begin to dismantle
civilization as we know it now as
far-fetched as that sounds it didn't
escape my notice that IT security
experts didn't immediately dismiss this
scenario and that that should tell you
something about the state of our our
culture's infrastructure because I don't
think it would take a singularity or a
greater than human machine intelligence
to trap the human race I think it could
be done with much simpler systems
because one of the things about narrow
AI which is what BOTS are is that they
are great at allowing a very small
number of people to run the
underpinnings of society well the great
mass of people make few or no decisions
of consequence which is one of my big
concerns in fact in fact I think soon if
not already it might be possible for our
society to run completely on autopilot
nobody at the wheel so you may you may
think wow Dan that that sounds pretty
unlikely but I'll go over a couple of
ways that might happen because to me
that's the fundamental question of our
time whether technology whose Arum
bellowing here whether technology will
will liberate us or enslave us and I
think we need to get busy answering that
question and soon because that BOTS are
not going away they're going to be with
us as long as civilization is here so we
need to get this decision is this done
right
so before I continue let me clarify some
terms when I say a bot most of you
already know that that it stands for
robot and I don't mean this and I don't
mean this and there are no circumstances
do I mean this fabulous dance from the
80s what I'm talking about is this it's
a software bot it's a software
application designed to accomplish a
specific purpose now this is the source
code for an e-commerce pot that scrapes
pricing information out of websites and
accumulates it into a database probably
to be picked up by still other BOTS so a
bot does one or all of these three
things and searches for information
retrieves information and acts upon
information and although these seem very
harmless these are really the building
blocks for the whole biological world
because cells retrieve chemicals and
enzymes pull them into the cell to act
as catalysts to create all of the
activity in a multicellular organism so
these are really as I said the building
blocks for the natural world so together
they're very powerful and knowingly or
not we've replicated this in the digital
world
now if you look at the last item act
upon that's the key one because that
might get us headed back in this
direction at some point but fortunately
not even Danny Hillis or Alexander Rose
can build one of these yet so that
leaves us with digital bots for now and
digital bots are powered of course by AI
and artificial intelligence basically
breaks down into two main branches and
I'm going to buzz through this because
I'm sure you're all familiar with it but
there's artificial general intelligence
now that's strong AI now and that
differs from narrow AI and that this
doesn't exist yet but there's questions
about when it might arrive now a lot of
the theories like Vernor Vinge's
singularity theory pontificating weather
are all of our networks might combine
and soon create some greater than human
machine intelligence
likewise reycarts while talks about his
the the belief that by the end of this
century machine and human intelligence
will merge into one and then of course
there's Kevin Kelly and is one machine
concept that all of the processors on
the world are starting to equate to
neurons in the human brain but the key
thing about this is that it's been
thirty years away for about fifty years
already so the only people making any
money on it are science fiction authors
and Hollywood which leaves us with weak
or narrow AI and these don't even try to
approximate even animal intelligence
they do one thing very efficiently and
they're everywhere they're all
throughout society as a matter of fact
they power the modern world and that's
because of the modern world consistent
largely of data we create mountains of
data and there aren't enough people to
go through it all and BOTS are supremely
efficient at pouring through mountains
of data that the modern world creates
and that's what gives them so much power
over us as people
finance telecom security manufacturing
all creating this data it's worth noting
that BOTS determine whether you get a
mortgage they set your FICO score as a
matter of fact BOTS might determine
whether you get a job interview because
resume scanners look for keywords but
BOTS also affect us on a much more
personal level even than that
radiology MRI these films are examined
pre-screened by BOTS for follow-up by
doctors if an anomaly is detected so
instead of hiring a hundred doctors you
can hire 10 it's hard to imagine a more
directly impact on your life it's a
matter of fact you better hope they've
written these spots well but of course
BOTS are also scanning through all of
your medical records to see whether you
need to have your medical insurance
canceled so so they're mining all of
this data but they're also listening to
us as well and speaking to us if you've
called an airline or a credit card
company recently you've probably spoken
to a bot and actually within the
confines of a given business transaction
BOTS can understand and speak reasonably
well with humans as a matter of fact
typical synthetic speech voice based
entirely on text synthetic voices seem
rather fanciful no I have one with a
Kentucky accent but that seemed out of
and of sorts for here but these voices
allow a cost reduction of up to 90% in
call centers and that's the key once
again is that bots are more efficient
than humans but of course bots are also
listening to us in other ways bots are
largely responsible for the removal of
the limitations on wiretapping because
BOTS can be put onto a line to listen
for key terms and once again notify a
human being for follow up so that's a
key thing they've removed any
limitations on wiretapping but BOTS are
of course also watching us the
ballooning number of surveillance
cameras out in society has made possible
largely by
we're because there aren't enough orcs
in Mordor to watch all of these computer
monitors there are 500,000 surveillance
cameras in the City of London two
million in the city of Shenzhen China
and it's software that watches these
monitors looking for suspicious behavior
like a sudden grouping of six or more
people they can increasingly recognize
us by the way we walk by our facial
features and also they can identify
people by race
so cameras sorry bots are really an
unblinking high and ever listening ear
and of course they make key decisions
about our lives based on our data and
that's why it's worrying that our
collective control of the internet seems
to be slipping someone now this graph
shows the growth of malware that is
botnets in the last two years during
this time there was a concerted effort
by government universities and private
industry to contain the spread of
botnets that is armies of zombie
computers controlled by BOTS and yet
during this time these botnets spread to
thousand one hundred and sixty two
percent and that's despite a concerted
effort to stop them so I would argue
that we're in a Darwinian struggle with
narrow AI and that nature is currently
selecting for BOTS and against humans
and one reason efficiency we're just not
as efficient in a structured society as
BOTS it's partly due to a confluence of
processing speed storage space increase
the spread of the Internet and bandwidth
has made this possible and any time you
bring a human in to do a job they bring
a whole bunch of other stuff in with it
like emotions philosophy goals which
BOTS do not bring so having a big brain
as we do is no guarantee of success and
in fact most organisms on earth do not
have a big brain and do quite fine
parasites for instance don't even have a
central nervous system much less a brain
and they outnumber all other organisms
on Earth three two one so having a big
brain is no guarantee guarantee of
success and as a matter of fact humanity
in general is not guaranteed a starring
role in nature's pageant and that's why
it's important to understand the scope
of this situation just look at the
numbers this is the growth of the
internet over the last 15 years come
from 1995 projected out to 2010 from 16
million to 1.6 billion people now that's
people using the Internet but of course
as that network expands so does the
environment for programs so this really
isn't a perfect measure of the growth of
the bot ecosystem a better measure would
be hard drive space on all of planet
Earth
fortunately someone's keeping track of
that as well and in the next five years
its projected to go up a thousand
percent for me a thousand percent which
is much steeper than the growth in human
users and we all know that our hard
drives are expanding in size and memory
and that creates a vaster environment
for BOTS to run in so we must be getting
some benefit out of this if we're
building this vast network for these
synthetic organisms well pardon the
purple it's actually blue on my screen
the human race is expanding in numbers
and that's good we learned how to fix
nitrogen into the soil but what about us
individually what about the value of
human life there it's a little different
story and this is a disagreeable looking
slide because it's about slavery and
many people think that slavery is a
thing of the past but unfortunately we
are living right now through a golden
age of slavery or 27 million slaves No
on the planet right now it's more than
at any point in recorded human history
so if we look in the United States that
what a healthy male sold for adjusted
for inflation it was $40,000 in 1850 in
the year 2000 traffickers sell a healthy
male laborer for $600 so clearly our
human stock is dropping which is
surprising because we're big brained
animals were the most innovative were
capable of great flexibility and yet a
rack server a good one goes for about a
thousand dollars so who is using this
network more this internet machines are
or humans sad news there too by 2010
Ziff Davis projects that machine to
machine transactions will outnumber all
human use of the Internet now partly
this is because of EDI electronic data
interchange from all the companies out
there
leveling inventories automatically
ordering things from each other
there's also sensors on pipelines and
smartphones and location tracking
devices but I put forward that we're
hooking and injecting into the internet
hundreds of millions of BOTS
without any clear consideration about
the consequences to humanity and also
there's no broad examination going on
about how these bots might interact with
each other
now that's without advanced intelligence
just simple reactions a good example of
that was Wall Street 1987 October 19th
twenty two point six percent of the
value of Wall Street disappeared and one
day and it was because of program
trading bots reacting to each other
there's half a trillion dollars in value
remember also that BOTS don't observe
borders they don't share our priorities
they don't need clean air or water and
they don't need liberty either so I
would suggest that BOTS are potentially
a vector for human despotism as well
because very few people are needed to
run systems with BOTS and as fewer
people make decisions fewer people are
needed to make decisions and they don't
learn to make decisions and that makes a
smaller number of people knowledgeable
enough to sustain civilization and we
might lose our ability to control
society so who's building all these BOTS
anyway usual cast of characters of
course corporations build tons of them
to encapsulate business knowledge
governments create mountains of data
that corporations and governments have
to mine you might be surprised to see
religions up there religions do things
like protect their Wikipedia page they
might create a bot to keep an eye on it
make sure nobody changes it and the good
thing about a bot is it'll work 24/7 and
it doesn't have to obey the Sabbath
criminal groups make some of the most
sophisticated BOTS out there because
they have to be stealthy in addition to
doing what they're doing and of course
there's just every individual student
researcher hacker grey hat white hat
black hat creating this a galaxy of
software that's doing who knows and this
zoo of bots I divided into two families
dative ORS that is bots that munch on
data and predators and you might be
surprised to see game bots on the
predator side but actually they inform
the malware and botnet family because
actually game bots are where some of the
most sophisticated software is being
made right now
the games online games in particular
reveal a lot about the future I think
for social interactions and especially
about our interactions with BOTS
artificial life so we have a lot to
learn
actually from from games I know it's
shameless to use kittens but I'm
actually showing this to make a point
all juvenile mammals indulge in play
it's our way of probing new realities
and of learning our place in them and so
I would I would argue that this is
fundamentally the same thing as this
because people are probing new realities
now as work becomes more network based
and less reality based this is very
useful I think it's one of the reasons
why people play games now well into
adulthood it's because the world is
changing so fast that we're continually
juvenile in at least one aspect of our
lives
games online games in particular are
also where humans interact most visibly
with artificial life-forms bots because
there are BOTS all over the place in
online games this is the game's second
life when this is the reporter Wagner
James ow conversing with a chat bot now
the difference here is that this bot
looks like a body the truth is in most
online games BOTS look just like we do
in games that is a ten-foot Panther with
twin scimitars but they're
indistinguishable from us visually and
the truth is nobody knows how many I
know they cover the children's eyes I
love the way he outs the gun nobody
knows how many BOTS there are in online
games I should have known better to have
a scrolling that's that's quite
interesting but you take a game like
World of Warcraft
that's an economy of 10 million people
and that's bigger in some real world
small countries actually I think I might
pause it I should probably pause it
before it gets to the really racy part
but
so if you're in World of Warcraft and
you're competing against BOTS because
people write BOTS to play World of
Warcraft and I don't mean to pick on
Blizzard here because any successful
online game where you can sell virtual
things like virtual gold or magic items
on the open market efficiency counts and
where ever efficiency counts you'll find
BOTS and so games like World of Warcraft
have BOTS in them and that makes it so
that players human players are competing
in this virtual space for virtual gold
and for quests against artificial
life-forms and this is not a science
fiction thing this is really happening
everyday and as more BOTS appeared and
players became irritated publishers like
Blizzard created programs like warden
and what Orden does is it tries to find
BOTS running on your computer
with the game client and as Blizzard
started trying to find BOTS bought
developers made them stealthy and it
created a classic Darwinian struggle
where the predator was chasing the prey
and the prey adopted a strategy of
camouflage and as a result rootkit
technology is now being driven and
mostly by games by game bots because
that's where truly stealthy software is
being created on a daily basis and if
sort of a an incubator
little backup one they here by the way
is an example of a botting system this
is one system playing nine characters in
world of warcraft so somebody went
through the trouble of writing a program
that can play the game for you but in
this case such a person could make
hundreds of thousands of dollars in the
real world by selling the items that
these BOTS gather don't once again
stealth I was able to sit down with dr.
Garry McGraw of digital incorporated
he's a foremost software security expert
he's also with Greg Hoagland the author
of the books sorry exploiting online
games and exploiting software and he had
this to say on the subject of game bots
and its implications for security
software in general the most interesting
thing that's happening now is you want
to build a bahding system that's totally
undetectable so that you can have this
game be played automatically and you
don't have to be there be present you
build a bot or an AI program to play the
game for you but it has to be
undetectable so a lot of work has gone
into stealthiness and hiding processes
and things that rootkits traditionally
do the interesting thing that happened
is the whole thing shifted and now in my
view rootkit technology is actually
being driven by gaming exploits so as an
example of how gaming technology is
leading rootkits can think about an
undetectable bot system that uses the
fact that most pcs today are multi-core
systems so strangely the game companies
have decided to monitor the game process
in user land on the same processor
however if you
use a hardware interrupt and just stop
that processor guess what else stops the
monitoring software then you do some
other exploit processing on the other
core inject the payload and off you go
and since there's no rip van winkle
monitoring capability yet on these
things you can get away with that and
build a insanely undetectable but these
days so who would have thought that such
sophisticated software would be put
towards playing games and that's why I
think online games are the larval stage
of something much more serious in both
our society and in our relationship with
bots in general this is an animation
that shows major botnet activity over a
seven day period in the world and once
again botnets are armies of compromised
computers so in red you'll see a storm
botnet and oranges the Kraken botnet and
you'll notice as the workday passes the
activity booms it's like an algae bloom
it's very much a natural system this is
what I mean about botnets evolving
serious stealth because remember no one
can stop these botnets no one their
numbers anywhere from half a million and
I love this the upper end twenty million
that's how wide the spread is nobody's
quite sure how many there are out there
and the creators of these botnets once
again nobody really knows who they are
but they're a very small number of
people who have a great deal of power
because they can rent time on these
botnets to either send spam or to direct
distributed denial-of-service attacks
against any target on the internet and
that has real-world consequences
I'd be one example a company named blue
security and her celaya Israel in May
2006 this is an internet security
company it tried to defend its clients
from an attack knocking their clients
off the internet
and the botnet then turned to blue
security focused its attack on them
prevented them from connecting to the
internet no matter what they did and
they eventually went out of business and
then the botnet turned its attention
back on its original targets that was in
Wired magazine in May 2006 now
information week has said that the
biggest botnets can knock entire
countries off the internet and the
Kraken botnet is estimated to have
already penetrated 50 of the Fortune 500
companies and remember very few
individuals control these and they're
the number-one threat to our collective
control of the Internet which is
worrisome in a way because BOTS are
increasingly passing for human in
everyday communications now by that I
don't mean they're passing the Turing
test this is more of a short form
touring dust you look at the way we used
to communicate writing beautiful letters
in the 19th century dearest Martha the
children and I are fine everybody had
different handwriting and we even had
difficulty reading each other's
handwriting but today very often oMG lol
simple symbolic language but again
that's not the way we typically
communicate very typically we'll go to a
website we'll choose from drop-down
combo lists multiple choice items these
are all things bots are capable of doing
and it's because we're trying to be
highly efficient in our communications
and accelerate things that it's made the
bar lower CAPTCHA cos can also be
defeated by bots those are the
completely automated public Touring test
to tell humans and computers apart the
little squiggly lines at the bottom of a
webpage those can now be cracked in 60
seconds by BOTS so that line is blurring
so when we break tasks into BOTS like
repetition as we are doing we remove the
value of the unique adaptability of the
human brain when we break it down into
simple structured systems the human
beings are also programmable as we've
seen in certain social setups any
society that values obedience and D
values independent thought goes into
this category
now the disciplines of propaganda and
advertising have been honed to a Razors
Edge to press our buttons and get a
predictable response so if you can't
tell a human from a bot what's to
prevent a bot from pushing your buttons
from getting you to react in certain
specific ways well you might think that
word would that would require that we be
visible to bots moment by moment and
actually as BOTS are exploding in size
and influence over us so too is our
visibility to them as a matter of fact
you're probably wearing this handy
tracking device it's a cell phone every
few seconds its position is recorded in
three-dimensional space and that data
doesn't go away it accumulates the same
is true of your financial transactions
all of these things build a picture of
you who you are and what you're doing
now Bruce Schneier the renowned
cryptographer and security expert calls
this data pollution that's the cost of
gathering data storing it retrieving it
has essentially dropped to zero which
means data never goes away so that over
time you can go back and determine where
somebody's been for years every single
moment
remember bots are uniquely good at
mining data and you may not have a
problem with us actually you might trust
your government or whomever but what
about ten years from now or what if that
data gets sold or maybe even to a
foreign government and if you travel
that might be a concern as well because
it builds a complete profile of you
probably more than you know about even
yourself
in 2005 mit research and Nathan Eagle
did a study called reality mining where
they tracked a thousand cellphones as
they moved around campus and at the end
of that study they wrote an algorithm
that could predict with eighty-five
percent accuracy what any individual was
going to do next
and that's the power of simple software
no conspiracy next necessary so you
might wonder what sort of data is being
gathered on a routine basis out there
and in reality now this is a typical
urban street once again this is today if
we zoom in we can see surveillance
cameras of course these are wired in
once again to a system the data is
archived and software is analyzing the
images keeping it for long periods of
time but those aren't the only
surveillance cameras out in the world
there's private surveillance cameras
possibly nowhere near as well secured
data for sale to divorce attorneys and
then of course up at the end of the
block some some weird guy with a webcam
pointed at the street once again
available to the web visible to BOTS all
of this visual data creates a context
for the other data points that are being
gathered by cell phones by smartphones
emails and so forth and then of course
there's the almost legacy process of
gathering license-plate numbers
programmatically to track automobiles
but that's less and less necessary
because new technologies make it easier
I'll pause this here now many of you
have Bluetooth device
in your car but you may not know about
the TPMS system this is the tire
pressure monitoring system it was
federally mandated by the 2001 tred act
that's right you're all remember voting
for this right it says that any car
manufactured after 2007 has to have
wireless nozzle pressure measurement
devices now communicate with the
computer onboard the car to see that
your tires are safely inflated now they
have to have a unique ID so that the
computer knows your tires from the car
next to you and of course it is an open
standard and it makes it very simple to
track the unique identity of an
automobile but of course to do that you
would have to have devices scanning
fortunately such scanners have started
to spring up at choke points throughout
modern cities these are privately owned
scanners the data being gathered and
stored again because it's cheap to store
data vast amounts of data this data can
be piled up along with your financial
transactions and anything else and BOTS
can go through it to find persons of
interest or do just find patterns or
even just to sell you stuff I'll give
you an example of just a few such
devices there's a blue sweep scanner and
a blue sweep scanner is a device that's
able to identify all Bluetooth devices
within its radius identify what their
capabilities are and what exploits they
might be vulnerable to a blue sniper can
do this up to a kilometer away let's go
a little further down the wall
there's the blue snarfer you are all
expecting now blue snarfer can use it an
exploit and given to it by a blue
sweeper to steal your address book your
text messages your calendar your
pictures of your kitties and a Bluetooth
car whisperer can push advertising into
your car speakers through your car's
Bluetooth system now more worrisome it
could also be used to hook into your car
Bluetooth phone system to eavesdrop on
conversations in the car now if you
combine that with something like the
TPMS system or any future open standard
device you could pretty much track a car
and listen to its occupants as they move
throughout the city at any point in the
future or at the moment it's happening
now so you're walking through this
gauntlet of scanning activity with all
your wireless devices and again I'm sure
we were all aware of this and then
there's of course the financial
transactions every time we buy stuff
with a debit card or a credit card who
what where when combine that with visual
data and all of the other points that
tell us who was there with you where you
were going it can be used to tell some
very interesting stories so it's a great
constellation of information being
gathered on us at all times and then of
course privately owned devices hovering
up all this information so this is the
world you live in right now who knows
what it will be like ten years from now
and this goes into the increasing
complexity of the bot ecosystem in
general because all of these corporate
mergers have created a vastly complex
system that no one really understands
you take mergers where they lay off half
the IT staff if half-finished projects
maybe BOTS running that are completely
forgotten doggedly pursuing some
original purpose that no one knows about
and also maybe even competing with each
other even though the company is now one
and not two and then of course there's
the occasional disgruntled employee who
takes over the network and I know that
sounds impossible but so this could lead
to a loss of human authority Oh humans
no longer fully being in control because
it's really a system where historical
decisions rule somebody or some group of
people created an algorithm that decided
something was true a while back and it
is put into force and other people obey
what it has to say and over time it
becomes a black box a proprietary
mechanism that might in turn be folded
into yet another algorithm which becomes
a black box unless people understand the
proof of the logic that went into that
algorithm a Kurt Vonnegut wrote a book
called the player piano where society
was completely on autopilot BOTS ran
everything including the factories but I
wonder if BOTS would be the ones working
in the factories because we might get
the crap jobs because you don't need to
have a body to manage a structured
process and that's what society has
become a structured process humans
offloading decision making Authority and
ask yourself would you notice do you do
you really know that 75% of the
decisions being made at your bank
aren't being made by BOTS right now
probably not so rather than rising to
some great complex Golden Age I am
concerned that human civilization might
take a sidetrack and head towards a
boolean age that is a a time categorized
or described as a constant bombardment
of categorical questions that you must
answer you can't pose any questions that
aren't asked directly of you and I think
we see elements of that already so
that's a structured existence in a
structured society and it is supremely
efficient and I think such a thing
could give rise very easily to an elite
group of people who would be the ones
who understand how society works and
everybody else just answering the
questions and here's a quote from Carl
Sagan's book demon-haunted world science
as a candle in the darkness Carl Sagan
wrote science is more than a body of
knowledge it is a way of thinking I have
a foreboding of an America in my
children's or grandchildren's time when
awesome technological powers are in the
hands of a very few and no one
representing the public interest can
even grasp the issues when the people
have lost the ability to set their own
agendas or knowledgeably question those
in authority when clutching our crystals
and nervously consulting our horoscopes
our critical faculties in decline unable
to distinguish between what feels good
and what's true we slide almost without
noticing back into superstitions and
darkness and I think that's the real
danger there is having a small group of
people understanding how society works
so that's BOTS as a control mechanism
economic disenfranchisement at the flip
of a bit and you might not even know
what went into making that decision
about you because remember we have vast
quantities of data about us and bots are
making qualitative decisions about us
all the time as a matter of fact it
might not be a person who decides who
makes that decision it might be an
algorithm what if control erodes further
though what if the last person who knew
how to stop something or the last person
with the password dies or quits I think
we could easily picture a bot controlled
corporation because corporations are
already termed unnatural persons in the
eyes of the law they have all of the
rights of a human being
privacy freedom of speech with a big
difference being that they don't ever
die and that's very similar to a bot so
what if steps were made by corporations
to give civil rights of some type to
BOTS for instance that you don't have
the right to delete them from your
system and that sounds a lot like DRM
actually come to think of it because you
got to ask yourself who controls the
data on your system and in these systems
that's a perfect example of humans
ceding some of their rights to bots
so where does that leave us I actually I
don't think it's this bad although I
have painted a very dreary picture if I
count through it I said that BOTS
environment is exploding in size their
power over us as increasing vastly
humanity's value is plummeting and let's
see we're losing control of civilization
but I do think there's hope
because one thing humans do supremely
well is adapt we're incredibly flexible
and adaptable creatures now bots are
inflexible without us and even primitive
human societies can innovate
tremendously when necessary and in
nature flexibility typically wins so if
we were to start over what would we do
differently well this is the long now
foundation so let's think big what if we
built a new internet just for starters
but this time built it to benefit the
greatest number of people possible what
if we tried to make it support our
preferred way of government that is
democracy because I think in the past
we've built systems as a tool for
society what if we made systems IT
systems the fabric of society itself a
reflexion of it could we build an
operating system for democracy could we
hard code our values into the DNA of
civilization I think we might be able to
I think a way that we could start this
time would be by building an encrypted
network a dark net to begin with that is
not open automatically to all comers and
I think we'd have at least a couple of
qualifications for entry into this
encrypted network
one would be that you are verifiably
human and not to be too exclusive I
think we could let some bots in because
they are useful when they behave but of
course we would have to know the source
code of these BOTS so any BOTS that we
would let into this proposed system
would have to be whitelisted that is a
critical mass of humans would need to
review the code and agree that they are
benign and of course any misbehaving
BOTS must be able to be banished by
collective human action that is a
critical mass of humans voting them out
and this would have to be baked into
this Network from the very start and I
think we would also have to have a
secure cryptographic hash algorithm to
make sure that the source code of these
BOTS doesn't change and once again if it
does bots are automatically expunged but
that still leaves the question of how to
differentiate bots from humans which is
what started this after all because they
are a potentially aggressive organism
and I think the answer to that is
literally all around us I think it's a
three dimensional space because if we
project this new network on top of
reality it's very difficult for a bot to
pretend to be us this has been called
augmented reality and has been kicked
around for a few years but I think self
defense against BOTS us developing a new
sensory perception is a an ideal reason
a driving reason to implement such a
system because that's what we need to do
is develop new senses now in my book
daemon such a system is implemented it's
called dspace in that and by projecting
data onto three-dimensional space and
seeing BOTS and other other organisms
coming at you when they want to change
your data that really simulates what's
happening because anytime your data
changes it is potentially a threat to
you but the human mind
is wired to see it graphically and if we
created an Internet much like this we
might better be able to defend ourselves
against these things now we would need
heads-up glasses or a haptic display but
we wouldn't need to wear them all the
time I think we could get a buzz on our
smart phone that tells us something's
changed and we could put on our
spectacles and look into the next
dimension I think we could do that but
the key is that in this type of network
you would be in control of your data
anytime it changed you would know it
because in the modern world already you
are your data if your data goes bad
you're in a heap of trouble
so this really is self-defense and I
think this dark net would operate in
parallel to the existing Internet and I
think people would opt into it to get
control of their data of nothing else
and especially I think they would be
willing to join a network where human
action collective action could banish
BOTS and I think this is already
familiar to us because we're already
doing this in games carrying call-outs
over our head projecting data onto
three-dimensional space when I said that
games online games are a larval stage of
something more serious in our social
relationships and in our relationship
with BOTS this is what I'm at I think
we're practicing for something and
online games social networks wiki's
online games we're exploring new
realities we're already working on this
as a matter of fact we already have the
coordinate system work down it's called
GPS so we built big pieces of the
infrastructure of this type of network
but how would a new network like this a
dart network person-to-person I think it
would look very much like an online game
walking with a call-out to those on the
network carrying your name
reputation your experience your skills
so that people can recognize each other
now people who are privacy advocates
might look at this and say oh my god
this is a nightmare
but I would point out that your data is
probably being sold to somebody just
this moment and at least in this new
network you would know anytime someone
touched your data you would know it
instantly you would receive your ratings
in such a system by your past
interactions with other network members
as you dealt with them they would rate
you and you would rate them and you
would classify their skills and this
would start to develop an open-source
database on what this civilization can
do collectively it would keep its
collective records as part of the system
and it's good to have reputation in
context especially if you're trying to
buy a car or something like this like
the undercoating I wonder if it would
encourage like-minded people to hang out
together to get better ratings and I'm
not sure that that's bad I'm not I don't
haven't decided yet but it might make
for some interesting changes in signing
but what about BOTS pretending to be
human because of course that's one of
the reasons we've designed this it would
be very difficult for a bot to
masquerade as human in such a system
because remember illicit bot spots that
do not have their code approved by a
critical mass of people would be
banished instantly which would leave
BOTS masquerading as humans as the only
way to get around but of course a
call-out hovering over nothing is a dead
giveaway and hiring people to hold your
bot for you doesn't scale very well it's
very expensive so this has a sort of
built-in natural protection against that
and I do think that this type of social
arrangement has even greater
implications
actually because bots although they are
a threat we've dealt with threatening
organisms before we've developed
symbiotic relationships with threatening
organisms before and the very
disinterestedness in of bots in us is
their great usefulness
because impartiality is a cornerstone of
blind justice and blind justice is a
cornerstone of democracy so one could
picture that open-source BOTS that is
bots that have their source code
reviewed by everybody and available to
all could be supremely useful and
impartial about human affairs and this
would be a bot mediated reality this
would be BOTS examining what's going on
in the real world and moving information
and decisions through civic society on
our behalf I'm gonna get a laser pointer
for this and step you through this
imposing diagram so here we see the old
dirty Internet and of course the new
dark net constantly gathering news about
the real world news items rumors blog
entries and there could be a layer of
civic BOTS open-source approved
gathering this information on a
moment-by-moment basis and distributing
small bits of it to citizens in this
dark net the bots don't have to know
what the news means they just pass it to
big brained humans who can sort it out
and as a citizen part of your duty your
civic duty would be occasionally to
receive this information and you only
have to do two things
you have to categorize it and prioritize
it so if you're walking along you
receive a message that there's been an
oil spill you might think that's a very
high priority item and you might
categorize it as ecological pollution
and send it on its way and then a second
layer of civic bots would gather all of
the information from all of
people who received that exact same item
and it might be thousands of people and
it would determine whether it was
collectively perceived as a high
priority and those high priority items
we'd already know the category generally
that people assigned it to and because
we collectively have been evaluating
each other in our past interactions we
know who the experts in ecological
pollution are in society and so with
these BOTS and they would direct that
high priority ecological pollution news
item to the experts in society and the
experts would further evaluate it they
would vet it and determine whether it
was in fact real whether it was in fact
high priority once again the bots don't
know they don't care it's just
information that's of concern to us and
that's why this is more of an operating
system for democracy we're collectively
deciding so these experts if they still
rate this as a high priority item the
next layer of civic BOTS would then
identify a high level high reputation
expert in ecological pollution take the
recommendations of the experts to assign
resources to it and put them in charge
and so this is a self-organizing system
there's no central leader its assignment
of political power on an as-needed basis
which evaporates when the need goes away
so there's no central authority nothing
to attack now in the past if everyone
could get 15 minutes of fame in this
system everybody could get 15 minutes of
power now there's still infection and
malware but a diverse open source system
like this can deal with that much better
because it's a natural system it's
constantly evolving there are many hands
involved in it because static systems
are doomed in nature as they are in
digital networks
so in conclusion now that I've warned
you all that although BOTS do permeate
the modern world and they present a
potential danger to us and they're not
going away I really do think that we can
achieve a symbiotic relationship with
narrow AI and I think we can make them
the impartial arbiters of a democratic
society when I think that's the type of
network we should be working on so thank
you very much
[Applause]
Daniel thank you
oh you're welcome brilliant thank you
thank you [ __ ] so those of you who
haven't read it for me it was one of
those remarkable experiences it happens
every once in a while you read a book
and suddenly the world changes in front
of you this is one of those kinds of
books that suddenly the world the future
what was possible changed for me and and
as you might have a kind what I do I
read a lot of this stuff and it is a
very very rare moment and that was one
of those very rare moments so thank you
thank you
it is hard to surprise Stewart it is
hard to surprise me you did it Bob so I
have a couple questions and then we have
a number of questions from the audience
but but first of all you began by saying
you know you're a software guy why novel
oh I don't know I guess I've always had
a novel in me I always wanted to write a
novel I have an English literature
undergraduate degree I finally used it
now actually I use it everyday in
talking to executives and trying to
translate between programmers and
executives that's where I use that
English literature degree well I must
confess it shows it's also a
well-written story it's a hell of a good
story so you know I mean it it shows
okay you know I have not everybody out
here is a software junkie what's a
rootkit a rootkit is a stealthy piece of
software that takes root access control
of your system and there are different
types there's a kernel rootkit which
essentially takes your operating system
and it slips underneath it and it runs
your operating system so when you try to
run antivirus the antivirus can't see
the rootkit because the rootkit says
uh-huh you're not going to detect me so
it's something that runs your system in
a stealthy manner thank you thank you
okay so you know obviously these bots
don't have values they don't have
aspirations they're just kind of
carrying out algorithms correct
they're very banal but of course we had
the wonderful excruciating phrase from
Hannah Arendt the banality of
yeah so does this imply that these are
in some sense evil that maybe we should
be getting rid of our cellphones that
these no no the the the the root of all
evil is well it's like this any
automatic system can be used for bad
purposes you could create a door closing
mechanism and then some jerk can put
some innocent person in the way and it
can smash them so it you know is
automated systems do exactly what we say
but they typically don't have a sense of
context so they can be invade to
accomplish some very bad thing by people
so if you get rid of your cell phones
and all this other stuff I don't think
it would help I think it's better if we
build in mutual safeguards so that if I
misuse a system you'll know about it
darknes yeah I think I think because
then then you know in order to get into
the system your identity is known and
that's the key I think to reputation
systems now I want to talk for a moment
about your use of nature as a metaphor
here maybe you don't mean it as a
metaphor yeah it's like what question
first of all you began with efficiency
is efficiency the only goal of a bot
once again I don't think BOTS have goals
it might be the only goal of the
designer of the bottom because I think
there's just drive for constant
efficiency and if I remember correctly
in nature in the absence of parasitic
infestation species will tend towards
parthenogenesis that is cloning and then
when parasites are introduced into that
system the genetic monoculture that's
been created quickly crashes so this
happens in nature and I think that's
kind of what we're building in real life
in our digital network system a
monoculture natural selection actually
worked for BOTS well we're the the
evolutionary mechanism for BOTS and I
think it's largely measured by
efficiency how much efficiency a bot can
achieve in a given task and also
survivability although we are constantly
putting a hardened shell around our
systems rather than letting the bots
fend for themselves in an open network
which I sometimes wonder about
because when you see a botnet get behind
a network it can very quickly cause
major problems I hope that answered your
question okay let's give it another shot
well that's all right let's go to some
of the questions from the audience
now Seth Franklin where are you over
here is it really appropriate to say
BOTS make decisions aren't they just
executing algorithms like a car or a
bicycle yeah correct actually they are
they're regurgitating decisions that
someone made possibly in some other
context but once again they'll do so
remorselessly so actually when I say
we're letting BOTS make a decision for
us they're following a logical pattern
those of you who used you know MapQuest
to get here you allowed a bot to make
decisions for you how to get here and
mostly that's not a problem so it's that
class of decisions that you mean correct
okay straight boolean yes/no right left
now it coming back to the the natural
metaphor is there any evidence yet of
BOTS actually evolving or mutating no
not on their own and I think well
there's there's genetic algorithms that
do that you know where you run several
generations by design that's by design
okay and bots once again if they don't
perform well or they don't sell well the
engineers go back and reconfigure the
algorithm in the hope that they become
more efficient or don't make mistakes
and inventory leveling applications are
a good example of that because if you
have too much stock around you've made
bad decisions in your algorithm so they
will evolve over time through human help
to become more efficient well okay but
what we see in in nature you know
organisms mutating either alone or
through various genetic combinations
what's going on there's a catalyst for
it somewhere yeah well what's going on
at the level of software that actually
makes that happen
I think efficiency is the driver I think
that is the the thing that causes
mutation that constantly seeking more
efficiency by humans once again we are
the evolutionary mechanism for these
narrow AI ages okay Bob
pick worry over there everybody over
here okay so now it's the Unabomber Ted
Kaczynski remember that because it's
getting you still president in prison
right he said at some point pulling the
plug will be more dangerous than leaving
it running yet
oh I would think to pull the plug
definitely we didn't pull the plug now I
don't know you've got a lot of people
although the systems that feed everybody
you know when there's a new story saying
there's a storm coming and then suddenly
go down to the supermarket and there's
like no food on the shelves it kind of
shows how razor thin the margin is so if
somebody starts unplugging these things
even just distributing food would not go
so well so that's why I'm saying it's
it's difficult
tell unplug it it would be disruptive
but I don't think we can unplug the
internet we have to grow something else
alongside it so he was right it's too
late now it's too late we live that was
my long-winded English major way of
saying I was too late okay so I mean
does this imply that we ought to have
changes laws government policies that
somebody wrote this but didn't put their
name on it what would help prevent BOTS
enabled oppression who wrote this
question a bot obviously right yeah he's
trying to figure out what you're gonna
say and figure out that it's right
against it all right so this is how you
know it occurred to me that you know
when I was talking about tracking it's
like I fo bot well don't good know that
it's the writing neat yes it is in fact
you know you're right it does actually
look like a PO so what was questioning
it
the question was what are their laws
policies that we ought to be considering
to prevent the ultimate takeover I would
say the one policy that would help is
many hands coding and having involvement
and say and how things are constructed
and I think right now very much big
business runs things and efficiency
drives big business so until those laws
are changed that put business interest
against ahead of pretty much all other
interests
I hardly believe that things could
change so as long as we're really just
trying to optimize the kind of
effectiveness of society how it's all
bracketing smoothly that our money goes
where it would say Goods goes where it's
supposed to the electricity runs the way
it's supposed to the telephone networks
the runs the way it's supposed to is all
of that we're trying to optimize why
then there's nothing we want to change
right except when a disruption happens
that that becomes more like a house of
cards after a while and we've seen
disruptions before in power supplies and
other things you know back when many
people owned these things individually
and they were all competing against each
other I think you would have a hard time
bringing the power grid down because
these people didn't connect it to each
other but now that it's a vast
monoculture you know a tree falls on the
wrong thing and the whole damn thing
goes down so you know that would be one
example max back there so you know if
you were a Marxist why what you would
are some nos and I'm not saying I own a
corporation which may or may not be but
this is a classic Marxist argument so
what about the notion so that humanity
must first be oppressed
in order to revolt why in fact the the
bots are part of the natural order that
will lead to further human evolution
because they are in fact our natural in
since we are owning yeah well you know
we're people who hire brains we have to
create competitors with in effect hire
brains to force us to evolve you know
guys with bigger muscles aren't you know
we're not going to trust and tigers and
lions and I sense a cycle so is this
really about us creating our natural
predator to be able to evolve that's an
interesting question is that the sense
of your question do you dig it
I suppose that's possible although that
kind of reduces it to this futile
gesture building a civilization if just
to then build something to destroy it
but I don't know I don't know the answer
to that and it's a pretty philosophical
question
well another philosophical question good
so what's left for Humanity to do once
our basic needs are met by box is it
just writing more BOTS well then then
you get to the question of what are we
here for
you know if society is gonna run without
us I imagine we'd start killing each
other pretty quickly
I do think humans need challenges and I
think if everybody's involved in trying
to make society enjoyable for the
maximum number of people I think we're
nowhere near to solving that problem so
that would give us plenty to do and I
think just making it supremely efficient
would make it really good for just a
tiny number of people so that's kind of
where I was hatched so sub-optimal
better yeah you know might be you know
cuz how many how many gulfstream v jets
do you need you know need you have one
I'll take one okay okay so yuppies
showed us something on screen that I
thought was actually quite powerful that
the image of the urban environment today
that we all inhabit and the array of
sensors within which we live and the
array of networks connected to those
sensors and the capacity to understand
manage manipulate distributes data in
very very rich ways so you know there
once was a time when we lived in such an
environment it's called the village and
the sensors were the eyeballs in the
ears of our neighbors right that's a
reputation set on and and so we you know
we lived in a not BOTS mediated but
human mediated sensory reality in which
we had no privacy right privacy is a new
phenomenon it was partially an urban
phenomenon or really rural for me you
lived out in the boonies or you could
live in an apartment nobody knew who you
were what you did you can walk the
streets and you could be anonymous and
so on so privacy is a really new thing
you've described the world with privacy
is over is privacy over I hope it can
make a comeback but the thing is you
talked about a village and when you're
walking around in a village if people
look at you you see them looking at you
and I think the big problem now is
people are looking at you but you have
no idea who or how many people are what
they're doing with the data especially
if you see some of the algorithms that
place you in certain categories that
would just amaze you
but it's because they're examining you
and they might know you that is the
developers of these algorithms better
than you know yourself so I think it's a
very different thing I mean sure it
involves privacy but I think it takes it
to a whole new level and it puts it
behind this veil where you have no
knowledge of what's going on behind you
behind the scenes so it's okay for your
neighbors to know but it's not okay they
wouldn't know either party no humans
individually I think would know I think
big corporations and organizations that
are that are mining this data for
patterns would know is anything we do to
change that well right now it's a done
deal until they're a major change is
legislated legislatively to do that and
I think that's tough right before what
could you do and what when you think
about legislation you could say you need
to declare you need to tell people and
you know you probably get these privacy
notices I just love the way you get them
every year and like no this year I'm
fine you can take all my data I knew
they'd make you fill it out every year
they'll wear you down eventually okay so
we you know a number of times here at
long now we've had the rise of the arts
challenging some of the ideas that we've
seen in the world of the sciences and
technology so you know we think about
the tinfoil hat to protect ourselves and
you know remember when we there were
pyramids and so on to protect ourselves
from the bad vibes the pyramids didn't
save the Egyptians didn't save you but
is there some defense mechanism that an
individual who tries to opt out of the
network in effect can do no no I think
right now if you if you don't want to be
Amish I think probably not because I
mean you need a cell phone you need
otherwise people look at your weird yeah
but huh now I don't think that's what
Stefan Hoyer where are you Stefan but I
don't think that's what you really you
meant using art as a kind of conceptual
defense for against a kind of uniform
mediated realities that what you meant
interesting I I would think the only
defense against this type of thing is
once again many hands building it
because then many hands would be
informed about it and I guess it could
be considered a big art project at that
point everybody creating their own
interpretation of what society should be
on other people interacting with it I
think that's as is that answering your
question at all Artbox art bots I'll bet
if you go to google and type in art bots
you'll probably find a whole club well
in fact there's a wonderful book by one
of our friends Pamela McCourt uh called
Aaron's code I think that was the time
so it's like fractals in a way it's just
repeating Pat was about in fact art bots
making entrusting okay there's a new
years old so it it exists the art father
we got are already out there a thin
question sure hey so what do you hope
for from the movie uh no I got to be
careful what I say here let's say no no
casting choices here no no good Tom
Cruise already oh okay okay okay I hope
they don't mess it up and I hope they
leave some subtlety in it but I have
good hopes for it I do and the sequel
those of you don't have a painful fact
this is a spoiler this is only Volume
one that's right there's a sequel fair
warning and we are anxious for when did
we get the sequel ah you'll have to talk
to Dutton about that because I was gonna
release it in November but now this is
gonna release be released January so
sometime after that it's I hope that
isn't most of it most of most any hints
yeah you'll like you like it yeah I have
my wife so that's it yeah right any
hints no no no hints no it hits maybe
you but I don't want to put it out yes
all right Thank You Daniel Suarez my
pleasure
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]